All right now that we have seen how to create grooms get them imported and apply materials to them
Let's talk about applying grooms to assets. Now. You can use a groom assets in several different ways
thanks to the groom component you can add groom components to actors or
Blueprints and no matter which way you decide to add your groom
You're gonna interact with the groom in the same way as soon as you add the groom component you will then
Have the option to assign a groom asset in a groom binding as well as
Whether or not it should use cars it cards in a cache and some other advanced features now
First off. Let's take a look at doing this just at the level asset
So what we're gonna do now is we're gonna add the mannequin and then add our groom asset to it
so let's just remove this one here and we're gonna hit ctrl space and we're gonna go to our
Mannequins and not animals. I'm sorry, but meshes. We're gonna grab our SKM mani simple
she's gonna drag that out and then all we need to do is go over here to the ad and we're gonna look for a
groom and
There we go
And once we have that we just need to come down here to the groom asset and select our hair and then just pull
That the hair up a little bit so that it kind of sits on the head there
The reason it doesn't exactly well in this case
I think it looks kind of cool
But the reason it doesn't sit there exactly on top of the head is that this groom asset is something that I just imported and
Wasn't specifically made for this mannequins head. Once you have a groom asset that is specifically made for your asset
You're not going to need to pull it up. It will come in and it will have that rock-solid
coverage that you're looking for
Now you can also do this exact same process via a blueprint
All you need to do is add a skeletal mesh and then your groom asset
Once you've added the groom
Component you go to your groom asset and then apply the groom that you wish and again in our particular case
Using the mannequin and this hair since they are not necessarily designed for one another
We are gonna have to move that hair up a little bit
Let's just pop over to the editor and take a look at this blueprint in action
So we're gonna come up here to content. So we have this BP room here
And this was simply made by right-clicking blueprint class
Selecting the actor and giving it a name of BP groom once we had it open and the blue
The viewport all we did was add a skeletal mesh and in our case
we give it this SK Manny and then we also use this animation asset just to show you that the
Hair can react to the the animation here
We also went to add and added a groom there we go. There's our groom and then with our groom here
We just applied our
groom asset the hair here and once we did that we just had to pull it up just a tiny bit you can see here up
about 20 and about forward on the Y about 10 there just to get it on the
characters head and that is all that we had to do and then once we've done that we can go pile and save
This and then we're gonna hit ctrl space and just bring this into the level and there we go. We've got a
groom on our mannequin
So again very very simple way to get groom going and you can use groom for multiple multiple things
We could have a groom for the hair
But we could also have something for maybe eyebrows or chest hair or arm hair or leg hair
We can do a lot of different things with groom inside of Unreal Engine